Hi.
I'm with Jen who's a lead designer
with Google Apps Accessibility.
And Jen has over 15 years
of design experience.
And today, Jen,
I'm really curious to get your insight.
Our students have learned about user
interaction and information design.
What else is important when it
comes to designing a good product?
I think one of the key things that
a lot of people overlook initially, but
is extremely important is accessibility.
>> Mm-hm.
And what's accessibility?
>> Accessibility is about trying to
make products that are accessible and
usable by all people regardless
if they have a disability or
not It's closely related to universal
design, which is all about the process
of making products usable by people
with all ranges of abilities,
as well as they can use them
in all ranges of situations.
So just thinking about if you
can envision a user using
your product with one hand, maybe it
wasn't designed intentionally for
that, but can they use it with one hand?
And this would benefit users that might
have certain motor impairments, but
it would also benefit users that maybe
have a hand busy holding a baby or
a large bag of groceries.
That's kind of the idea
behind accessibility design.
>> Okay, and you mention some of
the impairments that someone might have.
What other sorts of impairments
might people bring to a product that
might prevent them from successfully
using a product in the first place?
>> There's a number of common
impairments that we consider, and
they range from having visual
impairments, being color blind,
having hearing impairments, cognitive
impairments, and motor impairments.
And the thing to note
with all of these is that
there's a wide range of severity
within each of these impairments, so
you could have just slight vision
loss to being totally blind.
And the other thing is
that a lot of people
tend to have multiple
impairments at one time.
It definitely makes things
interesting to design for, but
it's certainly a reality
that we need to consider.
And one of the things that I always love
to talk to people about and remind them,
when you start to think about designing
for people with disabilities a lot of
people tend to kind of treat them as
like they're in a separate group.
And it's a group of people that you
could consider or could not consider.
>> Mm.
>> But in reality, we're all going to
have some sort of impairment most
likely and within our lifetime.
One of the important things that I feel
that people need to keep in mind is that
when you're thinking about people with
disabilities a lot of designers and
different people tend to think of them
as a totally separate group that may or
may not, or can or
can not be considered in the process.
But in actuality,
all of us are going to have a disability
at some point in our lives.
And these things can be temporary,
like a broken arm.
They can be situational,
like if you're riding a bike and
maybe can't see your small phone screen.
And they can be just natural
progression of aging.
So it's really important
to consider these things.
because if you're not,
in a sense you're not considering
how to design these products for
yourself at some point.
>> Yeah.
So, what other considerations, I guess,
or why would it be important for
entrepreneurs to think
about accessibility first?
>> Well, one huge thing is that there
is a large population of people
with disabilities.
There's a lot of great research out
there about the demographics of people
and we compiled some research and
noted that there are more people with
color blindness than there are native
English speakers in the world.
>> Oh wow.
>> So this is a huge population.
>> Yeah.
And just thinking as an entrepreneur,
that's a huge pool of people, and
an audience that you can tap into
from a financial profit standpoint.
Obviously, another motivator if
you're looking to get involved
in education or government.
>> Mm-hm.
>> There's some legal considerations
there and some legal standards
that you need to meet.
But I think most importantly, what we
have found is that, when you consider
accessibility up front, it often leads
to a much better product for everybody.
>> Yeah.
And what's one example of a product
like that that you've seen?
>> Well,
one really simple simple example and
a straightforward thing that everyone
can start doing if you're designing
a digital product,
is think about can a user
complete all the necessary tasks on
your product using just a keyboard.
So, not only is this beneficial to
somebody that uses a screen reader or
doesn't have the dexterity to use
a mouse, but it's also really powerful,
or useful, for
the power users that you might have.
>> Yeah.
>> That like to use keyboards,
because they feel it's more efficient.
>> Mm.
Cool.